-Finally, it is Thursday,
and it is time for WeTweet.
Here we go.
♪ -WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Now, welcome to WeTweet.
This is where we, as a group,
decides something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you five
different Tweets,
and we're all gonna vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You got them there?
Yep, you can vote
for all of these.
Yeah!
You can vote for all of these,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want.
We're gonna see the results
live here on the show.
Higgins, Roots,
do you have your clickers, too?
-Got mine.
-Whatever Tweet
gets the most likes,
we will Tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all
like it and WeTweet it.
-Ahh.
-It's a shared experience.
All right, you guys
ready for this?
Here we go.
The first Tweet says,
Like "10 Items of Less" lines,
Starbucks should have
a "Simple Order Line."
Hmm. Wow.
Not only did they not laugh,
they didn't move.
[ Laughter ]
That's not a good sigh.
-More like advice.
Yeah, [ Laughs ]
they just didn't --
Yeah, they're just like, "No."
Okay, I think you don't even
have to finish the song.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
Yeah, that's half and half.
Wow.
Yeah, 100's not bad.
♪♪
-Wow.
-Not great either.
-No.
-Okay, here we go. Yeah.
We're just warming up.
They don't necessarily get
better, by the way.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Just want to warn you there.
All right, this next one says,
"Don't expect a "bless you"
after the third sneeze,
just focus on
getting yourself together."
[ Laughter ]
-You set me up there.
-Yeah, Tariq's like that.
-Yeah, that's up there.
-That's if it'll go in.
-'Cause, I mean,
I'm not gonna -- Bless you.
-Yep. Bless you.
-Bless you.
Figure it out, yeah.
-Yeah, get yourself together.
-I love it.
-Yeah, figure it out. All right.
Here we go. All right.
I feel good about this.
-Yeah.
-I feel much better
than the first one.
Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drum roll ]
-Boyyy!!
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo!
-Whoa!
-Yo! That was almost --
-194!
-That was almost 100%!
-Man.
-That was a great one!
Thank you for doing that.
What a change of heart...
-Wow!
-...the audience had.
-Apparently they weren't
in line at Starbucks.
-They found
the Christmas spirit!
-Yeah.
-"Cause Will Farrell's
on the show,
they got all excited.
Yeah, I got it. I understand.
Uh, how about this
next one's here, it says,
"If pro athletes could hear the
helpful things I yell at the TV,
they'd play so much better.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
That's pretty good, too.
-It's a good one.
♪♪
All right.
[ Drum roll ]
Let's see the results
on this one.
Can it beat 194?
-Whoa! Not bad!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad!
-Not awful. 166.
-Not bad.
-No, it was very
positive audience,
I like this audience.
Very, very good.
Next up, here.
This next one says,
"If there's one thing
I'm really good at,
it's getting people to say,
"Wow. You look tired."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you.
-Too true?
Is that too true?
-All the time.
-I know, me, too.
All right, let's see
the results right here live.
[ Drum roll ]
Not bad, but still not as --
♪♪
This last one says,
"There's nothing more painful
than having a kid describe
Mincraft to you."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Come on, that's a good one.
-That is too real.
It's not gonna be 194,
but that's a good one.
-That's a good one.
It's not gonna be 194,
but I don't think this one
is gonna go all the way,
but let's see.
Let's see the results right now.
There you go everybody!
That's it!
Looks like we have a winner.
It is Tweet number two!
[ Bell dings ]
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like!
Give it a WeTweet,
and enjoy...